good afternoon
the covet pandemic remains a severe
threat
to people's health and to people's
livelihood we are
in a race against time the faster we
reach
our target of having 70 percent of the
adult population
in europe vaccinated the better the
chances we have
of containing the virus and the good
news
is vaccination is picking up speed
across europe
member states have received over 126
million doses of vaccines
as of yesterday and i'm happy to say
that today we have reached the 100
million vaccinations
in the european union this is a
milestone that we can be proud of
of these 100 million vaccinations
more than a quarter already second doses
that means that we have now more than 27
million
europeans fully vaccinated and this is
good news
but as we can see with the announcement
by johnson and johnson yesterday
there are still many factors that can
disrupt the planned delivery schedules
of vaccines
it is therefore important to act swiftly
anticipate and adjust whenever it is
possible
and we are doing everything in our power
to support
europe's vaccination rollout also by
increasing the supply of vaccines in the
coming weeks and months
and this is why i'm pleased to announce
that we have reached an agreement with
biontech pfizer
to once again speed up the delivery of
vaccines
50 million additional doses of biotech
pfizer vaccines
will be delivered in quarter two
beginning in april
those 50 million doses were initially
foreseen for delivery
um in the fourth quarter of 2021
now they are available in the second
quarter
of 2021 that is right now
and this will bring the total doses
delivered by biontech pfizer
to 250 million doses in the second
quarter
these doses will be distributed the 50
million doses that we have now
additionally will be distributed
pro rata population among the member
states
and i think this will substantially help
consolidate the rollout of our
vaccination campaigns
i want to thank biontech pfizer it has
proven to be a reliable partner
it has delivered on its commitments and
it is responsive to our needs
and this is to the immediate benefit of
the eu
citizens and population but let me
also focus on the medium term
to prepare for the future we are drawing
the lessons
from the first phase of our answer to
the pandemic
it is clear that to defeat the virus
decisively
we will need to be prepared for the
following
at a certain point in time we might need
booster jobs to reinforce and prolong
immunity
and if an escape variant occurs
we will need to develop vaccines that
are adapted
to the new escape variant and we will
need them early
in sufficient quantities and having all
this in mind and having learned the
lessons
in this pandemic we need to focus
now on technologies that have proven
their worth
mrna vaccines are a clear case
in point and based on all this
we are now entering into a negotiations
with biontech pfizer for a third
contract
this contract will foresee the delivery
of 1.8 billion
additional doses of vaccine over the
period of 2022
and 2023
and it will entail not only the
production of vaccines
but also the essential components all of
that will be
based in the european union
the negotiations we are launching today
and i hope to conclude them
very rapidly our further important step
in europe's response to the pandemic
other contracts with
other companies may follow we are in
this together
and we will win this fight against this
pandemic
together thank you so much
[Music]
you